what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we're going to be talking about
that spider-man no way home final
trailer something that a lot of you have
been asking me about ever since we got
that second main official trailer is
there going to be another trailer a
final trailer that sony and marvel
studios release before spider-man no way
home comes out in less than a month from
now ever since we got the new main
trailer we have been getting a ton of tv
spots for spider-man knowing home and
some of them are actually showing quite
a bit of new footage and have some new
dialogue and this is exactly what
happened with spider-man far from home
they had a new tv spot every day every
other day so this isn't that different
but let's talk about if there's going to
be a final trailer that could possibly
show toby maguire and andrew garfield
spider-man in that trailer and exciting
reminder hawkeye starts tonight i will
be back with my live watch parties we're
going to be starting at 11 30 p.m
pacific time we can watch together and
of course we'll be having our discussion
after the episode and my breakdown will
follow that and i'm still giving away a
spider-man collectible all you got to do
to enter subscribe to my channel and
subscribe to cosmic culture and leave
some comments on some recent videos that
giveaway ends at the end of this month
so i think one thing is for sure we are
going to be getting a lot of spider-man
no way home promotion within this next
month it's really funny how they made us
wait so long for the first teaser
trailer and then the main trailer which
came out a month away from the actual
release date which is insane but they
made us wait and now they're just giving
us teaser after teaser after teaser a
bunch of tv spots come out bunch of
promotions come out and i know a lot of
people are excited about this and some
people aren't some people think they're
giving away too much but trust me
they're not gonna give away the whole
movie we've really only seen a few
scenes we've seen doc gawk on the bridge
and we've seen what i'm going to call an
edited final battle and the big question
now is are we going to be seeing a final
trailer that maybe doesn't have some
edited parts in it but could perhaps
show toby mcguire and andrew garfield
now let me take you back to the main
trailer during that scene with the
lizard getting hit by a ghost it's clear
at this point that it's one of the other
spider-man hitting him in this scene
there are supposed to be three
spider-men two of them were edited out
of course to avoid that big spoiler and
apparently marvel and sony kind of
weren't in an agreement on what to do
here apparently sony wanted to show the
other two spider-man but marvel studios
said no don't show them let that be an
on screen in the theater moment which i
can definitely agree with but that was
for that trailer if they do a final
trailer which marvel studios is known to
do now will they show the other two
spider-man well first let's talk about
if there is actually going to be a final
trailer insiders such as daniel rpk have
said that they are unsure at this point
in time if there is going to be a final
trailer however here's the thing if
there is going to be a final trailer we
know when it's going to be they pretty
much announced it in the last trailer
they said that november 29th is going to
be a pretty big day that's when tickets
for spider-man noway home go on sale and
they actually dubbed this day spider
monday which is a play off of cyber
monday the monday after black friday
where they have a ton of online or cyber
sales now here's the deal you're not
gonna have a day called spider monday
and not do something big like release a
scene or release a new trailer
especially since they're giving us all
of these tv spots so no doubt we're
going to get something new that day and
it is possible they could promote on
stations like good morning america which
walt disney owns and marvel studios has
been known to do this a lot they usually
show some clips from a movie on good
morning america at some point spider-man
knowing home is probably going to be one
of the biggest movies of all time if not
the biggest of all time so it would make
sense that they would promote it on gma
now there's no guarantee that this will
be on the 29th but it does seem like
sony and marvel studios definitely have
something in store for us on november
29th when tickets go on sale after all
all of these new tv spots are showing us
new footage but again the question now
is will they show toby and andrew in
this clip or in this final trailer and
my gut tells me i don't think so if sony
and marvel studios couldn't agree to
show the three spider-man in the main
trailer i'm pretty sure kevin feige
would get his way again for a final
trailer could they hint at him sure they
already have we've seen peter parker
saying that he's gonna need some help
and alfred molina basically already
confirmed toby maguire spider-man when
he says you're not peter to tom
holland's peter parker and that's of
course because he knows that his main
spider-man is tobey maguire then in
another tv spot we have tom holland's
peter parker saying the multiverse is
real so they're already doing some light
teasing or heavy teasing depending on
how you look at it but i don't think
they're gonna go full out and simply
show them i think they might hint at
them and i would really really love that
maybe two shadows maybe some theme songs
but not the big reveal and i'm okay with
that because i want to see that on
screen in the theaters for the first
time yeah we've known about toby and
andrew for a pretty long time now and
yes we've seen leaked photos but we
haven't seen them when they appear we
haven't seen them meet we have no real
interaction between them that's been
leaked so everything that happens
between the three spider-men including
when they meet and them fighting
together we haven't seen and that would
be best left for the theaters but maybe
you all want to see them in a final
trailer and if you do let me know in the
comments yes or no in the final trailer
show them or don't show them i'm sure
that there are still a lot of people out
there who don't really believe that toby
and andrew are going to indeed be in the
film and they would really really love
some type of actual confirmation in a
trailer and i totally get that but at
this point in time i think we have
enough evidence that lead us to believe
that they are in the film to where they
don't really have to show them and also
if you don't believe they're in the film
and you go to the theater and you see
that they are in the film it's going to
be that much better of a surprise but
regardless something is going to be
happening on november 29th we're going
to get either a clip a new tv spot i
should say a big tv spot not like some
of these 15 to 30 second tv spots that
we've been getting but like a minute
long tv spot at least or there is a
chance that we could get a final trailer
marvel recently did this for the
eternals they gave us a teaser a main
trailer and then a final trailer and
then some tv spots of course after that
but november 29th is spider monday and
this is sony and marvel saying that so
be on the lookout and of course if i
hear anything else i'll be sure to let
you know be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can always follow me on
instagram twitter or tic doc and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you